Hello everyone, this is Steve Gilbert. Welcome to lecture 23, where we're going to talk about dynamic memory and the heap.
Now before we do that, we aren't quite finished with C-style strings.
And to do that we're going to talk about command line arguments.
So if you run a program, you all know how you pass arguments to a function.
But how do you pass arguments to the function named main?
Because main isn't called from another one of your functions.
So if you want to pass arguments from outside your program to the main function when your program starts, you use a different version of main.
And so these are always passed as an array of C-style strings, just like the count matches program we used in the last exercise.
Now to collect them you can use one of these versions of main.
Now this kind of should look a little familiar with you because it's kind of similar to what Java does.
In Java you have public static void main string bracket bracket args.
Well these two arguments are the string bracket bracket args part.
Now argc, that first argument, is the number of strings on the command lines.
You remember in Java, arrays have a length field.
And so string bracket bracket args knows how many strings are in it.
In C, they don't.
And so we have to pass the number of strings on the command line.
And that includes the executing program name.
So argc will always contain at least the value 1 anytime you run a program.
Because the name of the program, of course, is what you use to execute the program.
Argv is an array of character pointers.
Now again you might wonder why it's not a const char star.
And that's because in C they didn't have const char stars.
They just had char stars.
And so this again has been inherited from C and it's something we use.
Now you can use argc to check the number of arguments passed.
So if argc is 1, then no argument was passed.
And then you can print out some kind of error message.
Typically this is called a usage message.
You notice when I'm doing the usage message, I'm printing out the name of the program
and then whatever arguments they should pass here.
And I'm exiting from the program.
So you can use argv sub 0 to get the name of the program
and you can use c error to print out a usage kind of message.
You can use exit or you can use return if no argument is passed.
For instance, if you're running a program, it requires arguments.
You don't want to go on and do anything else.
You don't want to allow them to enter the answer.
The argument needs to be passed on the command line.
So if you want to process all arguments, you can use a loop.
So here I'm printing out the name of the program
and I'm going through all the rest of the items from 1 to argc
and I'm printing out the argument names.
Now argc counts the number of words on the command line
but it doesn't count redirection parameters.
So obviously here there's only one word on the command line.
I'm running the program ex and argc is 1.
Here I'm running the program ex and I'm passing arg1 and arg2, so argc is 3.
Here I'm running the program ex and I'm passing arg1
but I'm redirecting it to out.txt.
So the redirection parameters, the little ampersand and the out.txt don't count.
So this still is argc sub 2 instead of 1, 2, 3, 4.
OK, let's go ahead and try it.
So we're going to write a program called frp, file replace.
We're going to do this really simply, it's not going to be very, very fancy.
But the purpose of the program is to open a file and print it
replacing every instance of a given word with another.
Now when I say every instance, we're only going to count if it's found once on a line
rather than multiple times.
So the command line arguments are the name of the file to open,
the word we want to search for,
and the word to use as a replacement, which is optional.
If they don't supply the word to use as a replacement,
then we'll just skip or delete that word from the output printing.
Now there are some error messages and a sample dialog in the handout
and you're going to test your program by writing make tester.
Because obviously we can't say make frp because that simply wouldn't work.
Frp is a program where we're testing the main function.
So let's go ahead over here and look at frp.
So if there are less than two arguments supplied, we're going to print an error message.
Two arguments open the input file for reading the file line by line,
displaying the entire file on the console.
With all arguments, the second argument removed.
If we can't open the file, print an error message and exit.
Three arguments open the end file for reading.
Read the file line by line, displaying the entire file on the console.
With all instances, the second argument replaced by the third.
As you read the file line by line, use find to see if the desired string exists in the line
and then use substring to display all but the character you're replacing, the word you're replacing.
So here are some sample runs.
So I said ./frp and it doesn't have its arguments.
So it gives me the usage message.
Frp, you're supposed to pass the file to open, the word defined,
and then optionally what you want to replace it with.
Okay, I'm going to try it again. ./frp data a1.txt
Again, I have supplied at least the three arguments and so it gives me the usage message.
Here I've said .frp data.ax.txt her.
Well, this is okay for the command lines,
but when it tries to open ax.txt it says it can't open the input file a.txt.
The rest of them, here I'm trying to say, here's the original file a1.txt,
here I'm saying ./frp data a1.txt her,
and it's going to remove all the copies of her from inside here.
Here I'm going to remove, place all copy of her with Alice's in the output.
Now again, this is very simplistic.
We're not doing very complex where her could appear in the word there, for instance.
We're not checking to make sure that doesn't happen.
We're also not checking to see if her appeared multiple times on the line
and replacing all of them.
That would be more complex processing.
So let's go ahead and go into IC23,
go into frp.cpp,
and let's just write our code.
The first thing, we need a different version of main, don't we?
So we need to have int argc,
and we need to have char star argv, bracket bracket.
Second, we need to check argc.
So if argc is less than 3,
then we don't have the right number of command lines.
And so we can do "sr usage".
I'm just going to write, I'll use the argv sub 0.
We're file to open.
Second argument, we're defined.
Our optional argument, replace with.
Notice I'm printing this on CR.
And I'm going to return a value here, since this is a main function.
I'm going to return a value -1 in this case.
Now, if I get down to line 12 here,
I know that I have at least 3 words on the command line, or 2 arguments.
And so I'm going to try and open the file name.
So I'm going to say "if stream in",
and I'm going to do "argv sub 1".
"argv sub 0" is the name of the file, "argv sub 1" is the file name.
Now I'm going to check if that worked.
If "in" failed,
"sr could not open argv sub 1".
This time I'll return a different number,
so someone running this program could tell from the numbers I return what the value is,
or what the error was.
OK, so now I've opened the file.
I know that I have found,
I've been able to open the file, I have at least the right number of command lines.
And so I'm going to, and I often do,
use the C++ string class to make the rest of this easier.
So even though "argv" is all C-style strings,
I can construct C++ strings.
So I'm going to say "string word = argv sub 2".
I'm going to say "string replace",
of course that's going to be the empty string,
and if "argc" is greater than 3,
in other words if we have four words on the command line,
then I'm going to say "replace = argv sub 3".
OK, the fourth thing in the array.
OK, now the rest of this is pretty straightforward.
We're going to say "file",
let's get a line here, "string line",
"get line in line".
Well we can read a line.
First we want to find out if we can find the word inside there.
So we'll say "autopause" or "sizeT" pause
equals "line find word".
Now if "pause" is not equal to "string in pause",
probably remember this from the first couple of weeks,
then we want to make "line" equals "line substring 0",
"pause characters",
plus whatever the replacement string is,
plus "line substring",
"pause" plus "word size",
and that's the rest of it.
Now as I mentioned, suppose the word appears multiple times,
we're not checking that.
Suppose the word appears inside another word,
Suppose if the word doesn't appear inside another word,
what about the space before and after?
Again, we're not checking that, we're assuming that the space is going to be OK.
So, very rudimentary, just to show you how to use the command lines.
And then we'll do "cout line endo".
OK, so let's do a terminal here,
and then let's do "make tester",
and that didn't work.
Let's do "make test".
OK, I should have just done "make test" instead of "make tester".
I'll change that on the slides, and I'll check on that later.
Let me just change the slide right now.
OK, so it checks the different command lines here to make sure they work,
they all do, then it checks some different files to make sure it replaces
one word with another word throughout there.
And that works OK.
Alright, let's go on.
And go to our second topic today, which is the heap.
Now, like Java and Pascal, C++ places variables on the heap using the new operator.
So look at this little piece of Java code here.
We create an int a and put 3 in it. That's put on the stack.
We create a double b and put 5 in it. That's put on the stack.
By the way, Java and C++ work the same way here.
Then we create a scanner variable in. That's put on the stack.
But we put a scanner object on the heap and point that variable to that scanner object
by using the new operator.
We do the same thing in C++.
So variables are allocated on the heap by using the operator called new.
The result that you get back from new is an address.
And we will store that address in a pointer.
So here's an example.
So int *pi. pi is a pointer to int.
And we initialize it with a new int with a value 3 inside it.
Here, ia is a pointer to an int.
And we initialize it with the address of the first element of a new array of 3 ints.
So very, very similar to what you do in Java.
Slightly different, but similar.
The big difference is in Java, when you put something on the heap with new,
Java will take care of returning that memory to the operating system so it can be reused.
In C++, that is not the case.
In C++, you are responsible for returning the memory to the system.
And so you do that with the operator delete, which is paired with the operator new.
If you use a plain new, like new int, then you use delete on the pointer.
Delete p1.
If you use the array version of new, new int bracket bracket,
you use the array version of delete.
So I'm going to show you an example of this.
And I'm not sure how this is going to work with this recording.
So I'm going to try this.
I may have to get the page off of another.
I want to continue.
So it dropped it over on another page here.
So I have a program here that creates an int a1.
Where is that variable going to be created?
It's going to be created on the stack, and it's going to be initialized with 1.
Now I'm going to create a new variable on the heap and a pointer on the stack.
So b is a pointer.
This new variable, which is unnamed, is pointed to by b.
And so this is what we end up with.
So this is a new object on the heap.
Now in this visualizer here, it shows this as an array,
but it's a single variable on the heap.
Now I'm going to create a new array of 5 integers.
I'm going to initialize the first 3.
So notice I'm using new bracket bracket here, not just plain new.
And so here I have my 5 elements on the heap.
And finally I'm going to create an array of 3 variables on the stack.
So int d bracket bracket equals 4, 5, and 6.
And so you can see these are created on the heap.
So this is what this looks like in memory.
Now when I delete c, you remember c used the array version of new,
and so I need to use the array version of delete.
When I delete c, the memory on the heap is returned to the operating system.
The pointer c is not changed, but it's no longer valid.
That's why these visualizer people decided to use a poop emoji
to show you that that pointer is no longer useful.
The same thing with b. When I delete the pointer b,
it doesn't really change the pointer, it makes it invalid,
but it's just the same address, it's not really touched.
But the thing that was on the heap goes away.
And so that's what this new and delete works like.
So let's introduce some dynamic variables and do an actual exercise.
So we're going to request some memory on the heap.
We're going to allocate memory on the heap with the new operator.
So let me show you the different ways that we can use the new operator.
We can say new and get an uninitialized variable.
So new int will give me an int on the heap,
p1 will point to it, but that int could have any value at all.
If we say new int with braces around it,
this is only available since C++11,
we would get an int that was initialized to zero.
If we say new int 3, here we can use either the braces or the parentheses,
this will be directly initialized, one single integer.
If we do new int square brackets, that's array new,
that will give us an uninitialized array.
If we use the braces around it, again only available since C++11,
that will give us three integers that have the value zero.
If we initialize it afterwards, we will get the 1, 2, 3, that will be initialized.
If we did this with an object, like an employee,
we would just do new employee and then initialize the employee like that.
So let's go ahead to our exercise over here.
Let's close firp and close that terminal.
Let's go to B.
Here are some automatic or stack based variables.
An int, a double, a float, a char, a string, an array, an employee.
Notice we print them just by using the name of the variable.
We're going to create dynamic variables for each of these.
Those dynamic variables are going to be unnamed,
and they're going to be pointed to by a pointer.
So I'm going to have int pointer ip for an int pointer equals new int.
I'll initialize, what was my int up there initialized to?
It was initialized to 3.
I'll initialize mine to 4 for this new one.
So then we have a double.
So int star dp equals new double.
That was 2.5.
I'll do this 3.5.
Int, that's a double.
A double pointer dp.
This is a float pointer.
Fp equals new float.
That was 2.5f.
I'll make this 3.5f.
I'll make that 4.5f.
And then a char pointer.
So char pointer cp equals new char.
Again, we can use braces or parentheses.
And we want the character s.
We want a string pointer.
New string.
That's my last name there.
I used the first name in this one up here.
We'll use an array.
Int star ia instead of ip equals new int.
This time we have to put in a value.
So I'll put 3.
And I'll put 4, 5, and 6.
Now unlike regular arrays, when you initialize a new array on the heap,
you have to supply a value here.
So if we were to do this, which would be perfectly legal for --
if we left off the --
that would be perfectly legal, right?
But for a new array,
you have to put the size in there.
And finally we had an employee, right?
So employee pointer ep equals new employee.
And we'll do a bill.
And we'll give him a slightly higher salary, $24,000.
Okay, so this creates the dynamic variables.
Now we want to go ahead and print those dynamic variables.
So let's look at how we would print each of those.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to take this here.
I'm going to copy it right down here.
Star ip.
Star dp.
Star fp.
Star cp.
Star sp.
So ia.
And remember with pointers, we can use the subscript just like with an array.
So I can say ia sub zero.
Ia sub i.
And finally the last one is an employee.
This one's a little bit different because I don't have an employee.
I have an employee pointer.
And so we'd have to say ep not dot name but arrow name.
And ep not dot salary but ep arrow salary.
Okay, so let's open a shell on that.
And let's do make test.
Let's just do make run.
Okay.
Okay, so I got an error.
Let's see how we created the employee up here originally.
Okay, so we created the employee like that.
So let's put the braces because it's a structure.
It doesn't have a constructor, which we'll learn about a little bit later.
And let's try that again.
Make run.
Okay, so an int is three.
IP is four, 350, 450.
CP is S.
SP is Gilbert.
An array is 456.
And ep is Bill.
And that looks like it works perfectly fine.
But there's a slight, slight problem.
There is a slight, slight problem.
So let's look at that problem.
We didn't have any errors.
Is everything okay?
No.
Unlike Java or unlike C#, we are responsible for returning any memory to the operating system.
The memory that's allocated on the heap is not automatically collected and reused.
And so we have additional programs.
One is called Valgrind in Java.
Windows has its own program that does this.
There's no universal way to do it.
I've also used some Google memory checkers to check that.
And I've put those in the make file.
So if we do make grind, you'll see that it runs a memory detector on it.
And at the end, it tells us, it runs the program up here, right, just like it normally would.
But at the end, it tells us, oh, we lost some memory.
And it's kind of telling us where it was lost on line 44, line 41, line 43, and line 42 and so forth.
And line 46.
And each of those, we allocated some memory, but we didn't free the memory.
Now, that's one way.
That's actually running our program by running a separate program called Valgrind.
If you look at the make file here, you can see that it runs Valgrind and then just runs the executable after the executable is built.
If we do make check, what it does is recompiles our code with a special kind of code inside it.
And then checks it that way.
So let's go ahead and do make check.
And it just depends which one you want to use.
So make check.
And let me close that over to that way.
And so basically we get the same information.
We don't get the startup thing at the bottom of it, but it tells us at the bottom where our code is leaking.
And it tells us here, you look for your piece of code, dynamic CPP line 47, 46.
So both of those will give us the same piece of information.
They do it in a slightly different way.
If you use Valgrind, you don't have to put any special code inside your program to do it.
It works automatically on code that has already been compiled.
If you use the checker, it automatically has to recompile your code and add this extra checking code inside your code.
So how do we fix this?
How do we fix this problem so that it works correctly?
What we do is we use delete or delete to return the memory.
You delete the pointer to free the heap object.
Just like the visualization I just showed you.
So let's go back to our code.
Let's bring this down here.
So I have delete IP, delete DP, delete FP, delete SP, delete CP, delete IP.
No, EP.
And finally, bracket bracket, IA.
So you have to check and fix the run time errors for each one.
So once we've done that, you can do either make grind or make check.
So make check.
If we got all of them, we won't have any errors at the end of it.
Make grind would do the same thing.
Now what if we use the wrong version of delete for this?
What if I for instance said delete IP or delete IA there without the brackets?
Let's see what happens when we do make check.
So notice that creates an error.
So we're using operator new versus operator delete with the brackets.
That's an error.
And this actually aborts because it would create more errors.
Because we're actually trying to allocate.
We're trying to deallocate memory that's on the stack, which is not legal.
And so you have to be careful to make sure that you use the correct version of new with the correct version of delete.
Let's do it one last time.
And no errors on that at all.